Oh
do this looks really cool what from
again but basically it was kind of gold
an impressive trick shot I just totally
blocked blanked out for the the end we
know what happens after but what is just
simply a setup so we have a little bit
of an issue with battleborn shoot we've
got 8 days to shoot it we haven't even
gotten the final concept finished and we
haven't even signed the statement of
work and so Nick and I are looking at
what it would take to make these props
we can't end it with a two minute long
sequence of repairs I'll just go wrong
the sixth one just goes wrong it's
nothing it to go wrong it cuz it only
goes wrong at the end well yeah but then
it goes wrong at the end someone's
almost dead and you're like crap what do
we do can't trickshot your way out of
this one like we've done that formula
and a lot of videos and it doesn't hit
hard well the only reason I say to do it
tomorrow is because the clients coming
over on Thursday morning how long can
you go at the stand mixer I mean really
that's that's my whole thing makes
mixing a breeze no we're in this is goin
to see I've been walking here for about
five minutes and I think I'm lost
yeah where your kitchen appliances find
ourselves a mixer
apparently standing mixers are made out
of gold and diamonds and unicorn hair
Jake you look a bit tired I am tired man
we're shooting a video on Friday a
commercial or shooting two videos next
week and shooting probably a video after
that putting together 2 pitch decks for
two different feature films that were
trying to get off the ground
these wiggly ones aquilae I need I need
to interact whoa I just turned it on to
a spectator view oh I have a camera in
my hand
that's cool actually it outlines the
entire field of view of the camera
that's super cool or you could actually
take a control or tape it to a camera
just hold the trigger and like eyeball
it so close you can get EMF you still
have like a dreary day yes how many
still has bills mm-hmm that's not it's a
little
he's an item he's a Miguel this is high
over the challenges of the day with dr.
justice we are currently working on a
pre-production booklet I used to say a
man could fly you'd have wings one of
the actors has no head shots which kind
of makes me putting him in the
pre-production booklet a little
unprofessional can I put in pictures
from his Facebook profile in like a
professional commercial document yes I
don't know how the clients going to take
that I guess we'll find out next on the
battleborn front we've finally got the
script and statement of work sent over
and we're waiting to hear back I think
it's pretty funny
now totally flat and very jittery
because I'm literally using my thumb so
here's the box I wish I need the other
controller up here okay so here's the
other controller you can see going
around the box we I can stand up box oh
so I get it like synced up and really
cool be like drawl and like see it in
your life footage that's cool though
like what kind of it works yeah that's a
Yankee but you know it's my two hands
like this we're ghost hunter costume
number one gonna find some ghosts guys
we were shooting something in the camera
just stopped recording I think that's
our proof right there we're not going to
show you anything because I would just
be you know to concrete we got to go
with the themes of the real ghost shows
and just not show just trying to
give all these you know little gadgets
and
should be pretty fun so yeah today I'm
just getting all the costumes together
let's wish them luck here that
holy holy
ah ah that's crazy look at this